this is one of our writers and one of my
very dear friends Joe DeRosa and I've
always wanted to get the audience of
this show in on something that we do
around the office where I do an
impression of Joe that's one of my
favorite things to do we've never
laughed so hard doing this kind of
impression together because to tell you
a little bit about Joe he's a he's a
very open guy he's very complaining he's
angsty I don't know how do you say it I
love you very dearly but there's always
something kind of Urkel yeah yeah like
for example what's what's hurting you
right now ah I think a raw pork the
other night not sure I'm not cheering I
was real hungry when I got home from
work we work such long hours on this
goddamn truck
no I we I got home and I was so hungry
and I was like rushing to cook and I
made these pork chops and I just sat in
front of my TV I just eating them real
fast and even looked down and I looked
down finally it was all red we may think
I'm gonna get sick from pet I don't know
I'm worrying about it that's a classic
Joe and that's the sort of thing yeah
that I would then for the rest of the
day just keep repeating we actually had
someone at the art department make a big
Joe for our office so just to give you a
take to be like ah and then cook the
pork ate it with my hands and they don't
feel
it always search with homes there's
always something so I started making up
fake things that Joe could say and this
is how we we start every day it'll be
like homes how much pepto-bismol can you
drink before you die the whole bottle
too much I wondered that taste good you
want to keep dropping it a little bit
chalky its chalky he think homes yeah I
got him to fight without him John he's
gonna write an album about me palms I
went on a horse ride turns out it was
just three goats there was a troll there
oh I got tricked into buying a boat the
guy said life at sea is the wave of the
future
I got buyer's remorse on that boat homes
my head hurts it's making me laugh so
hard right now normally your head hurt
I'll make more the MRI dude actually I'm
worried I'm having a strange headache
behind my eye and I think it's a tumor
but then it jumps to the other eyes
should I know
homes I got one of those jumping tumors
which I wants to kill me where oh yeah
let's go back there these are actually
on cards if you book I went a little out
of order
oh we got to do the gnome one oh yeah
he's run my favorites Holmes I met a
gnome
he told me secret he showed me how I
died even even if they sound good at
first they're not as like Holmes I
invented time travel the burdens too
great that's where we go what's wrong
with Joe DeRosa everybody